- Thanks to Mack Weldon for
keeping Legal Eagle in the air
and helping me look fly.
President Trump caused quite a stir
when he tweeted that the
election should be delayed
because Democrats were about
to commit mass voter fraud
by encouraging people to vote by mail.
Now I've already covered the
possibility of election delays
in my video, "Can the
President Cancel the Election?"
And I and most people
came to the conclusion
that because the election is
enshrined in the constitution,
that President Trump
probably cannot delay
or cancel the election.
But President Trump's recent
comments about voting by mail,
raise a different issue entirely
not canceling the election
or postponing the election,
but voter suppression.
And according to the President,
voting by absentee ballot is safe
while voting by mail is unsafe.
Apparently unaware that those
are basically the same thing.
Then the Trump Campaign recently
sued the state of Nevada
for its plans to send every
registered voter a ballot.
Now, why are states suddenly interested
in increasing opportunities
to vote by mail?
And are there legal insecurity differences
in how mailed ballots and absentee ballots
are handled and counted?
And does the president have the power
to change the way that
states run their elections?
Well, today we're going
to learn about the laws
that regulate elections,
the prevalence of voter
fraud or lack thereof,
and the safety of mail-in
votes and absentee ballots.
(upbeat music)
Hey, Legal Eagles, it's
time to think like a lawyer
because we have an election coming up
and the presence of the COVID-19 pandemic
has changed absolutely everything.
And I never thought I'd say this,
but it appears that the
president is trying to get people
not to vote in the November election.
- I've said it before,
and I'll say it again.
Democracy simply doesn't work.
- So the first question we need to ask
is who regulates voting in general?
Well, there's actually a fair amount
of federalism in voting.
The U.S. Constitution Elections Clause,
Article one, Section four,
empowers the states to
determine the quote,
"Time, place and manner"
of congressional elections
subject to Congress's authority
to make or alter state regulations.
Dividing the power between the
states and federal government
is a cornerstone of American federalism.
state and local governments
therefore have the authority
to enact laws for such elections,
including rules concerning public notices,
voter registration, voter protection,
fraud protection, vote counting
and determination of election results.
However, Congress may pass federal laws,
regulating congressional elections,
which then automatically preempt
any contrary state statutes.
And Congress can also
enact its own regulations,
if the states didn't
address something important,
but remember both Congress
and state governments
are constrained by the other protections
guaranteed by the constitution.
For example, if a state
imposes barriers to voting
that violate the 14th Amendment,
the laws can be challenged
as unconstitutional.
During the Jim Crow era,
states enacted laws designed
to stop black voters
from voting such as literacy tests,
property ownership requirements,
and mandatory of fees known as poll taxes.
But for the most part,
the laws that regulate how a person votes
such as what time the
polls open and close,
the deadline for registering
or the assignment of polling places
are all examples of decisions
that the Elections Clause
of the constitution
allows for the states to make.
So the vast majority of
laws that govern elections
are handled by the states
and neither the president,
the executive or Congress
has anything to really say
about that particular regulation.
But what about election security?
Congress has never passed
significantly legislation
mandating security
procedures for paper ballots
or electronic ballots,
even elections equipment,
including the software
from private vendors
is mostly unregulated.
And in the absence of federal laws,
states have developed their
own security protocols.
Many experts have argued that Congress
should probably step in and
regulate security procedures
to create uniformity amongst the states,
including federal agencies,
and actually in November of
2019, several federal agencies,
including Homeland and Security,
the Justice Department and the FBI
released a joint statement,
naming election security as quote,
"A top priority for the
United states government."
These agencies were chiefly concerned
about threats from foreign
countries and other bad actors.
Congress did not pass an
election security bill
after this warning.
And when Democrats tried to add funding
for voter security measures to legislation
addressing the COVID-19 crisis,
specifically targeting the
safety of voting by mail,
President Trump described it as a scam
to stop Republicans
from winning objection,
stating quote,
"You'd never have a Republican elected
in this country again if
the money for mail-in voting
was included in the bill."
And there is some truth to
the President's statement,
even if it is a crass political truth,
which is that research tends to show
that when voter turnout goes up,
it favors the Democrats and
disfavors the Republicans,
but saying that you actually
want lower voter turnout
is a bit like saying
the quiet part out loud,
but that takes us to the COVID-19 crisis.
Now, before the COVID-19 pandemic,
the main concern about the
security of voting systems
was the software and
hardware used to tally, scan,
collate and report votes could
be manipulated or hacked.
And truthfully that probably
deserves its own video
because our electronic voting systems
are woefully inadequate
and really need additional
security measures.
But the primary concern changed
when the COVID-19 pandemic hit.
No longer were people so worried
about the electronic voting at
actual formal polling places,
but instead, people didn't
want to leave their homes.
And since we don't have a system
of being able to vote
electronically from home,
the emphasis changed to voting
by mail and absentee ballots.
And in a way, this seemed
like a perfect solution.
People could vote from home,
minimum using the risk of transmitting
or receiving the COVID-19 virus
and many politicians on
both sides of the aisle
and many different states were
trying to encourage people
to vote by mail.
Now I have been using the terms,
absentee voting and voting by
mail almost interchangeably,
but let's talk about the
difference between those two terms.
Practically speaking, as a
regard to an individual ballot,
there's almost no difference,
if you vote by mail or vote by absentee,
you are taking your ballot,
you're filling it out at
home or some other place,
and you're mailing it into the place
it's going to register your vote.
Really, the only difference
is in terms of scale,
an absentee ballot is sort of an exception
to the general rule.
If you're unable to go to
a physical polling place
or you live outside of
the state temporarily,
then you can ask for an absentee ballot,
you can fill it out and then
send it into the polling place
as an exception to the general rule
that you would have to go in in person.
Voting by mail is
effectively the same thing,
just a difference of scope.
Instead of asking for an
absentee ballot as an exception,
everyone can vote by mail
regardless of whether
they meet the criteria
for an absentee ballot or not.
And states differ in
terms of whether you need
to formally register ahead
of time for a mail-in ballot,
or whether the state will just
send every registered voter,
a mail-in ballot without
having to preregister.
And while voting by mail
is certainly getting
a lot of scrutiny now,
it's definitely nothing new.
Some states, including
Washington, Utah and Colorado
have been voting only by
mail for several years.
Initially mail-in voting was supported
by both Republicans and Democrats.
However, President Trump was
disturbed by this development
and he started tweeting his concerns
about alleged differences
between absentee ballots and vote by mail.
In the President's mind,
it appears that absentee ballots are good
and mail-in ballots are bad.
- And you get thousands
and thousands of people
sitting in somebody's living room,
signing ballots all over the place.
No, I think that mail-in
voting is a terrible thing.
- Does that really happen?
The short answer is, no,
because there's little
practical difference
between the absentee
ballots and mailed ballots.
President Trump's own lawyers
even admit this in a lawsuit,
challenging Pennsylvania's
mail-in voting rules.
The President's campaign says, the quote,
"The terms 'mail-in' and 'absentee'
are used interchangeably
to discuss the use
of the United states Postal Service
to deliver ballots to and from elections."
So let's dig in a little bit deeper
into the various states voting laws.
All states allow voters who have a reason
they can't vote on election day
to request a ballot in advance.
Well, a majority of states
currently let all voters
ask for a ballot in advance
without needing an excuse
for why the person can't vote in person.
And some states adhere to
the traditional concept
of an absentee ballot.
An absentee ballot
technically is an old term
that meant someone was voting by mail
because on election day
they would be absent
from the jurisdiction in which they lived.
And 16 states still only
permit certain voters
to request an absentee ballot by mail
when they have an excuse
for not being able to vote
at the polls on election day.
Either that they won't be in
the jurisdiction on that day
or that they have an
illness or disability.
This is the traditional
meeting of voting absentee.
In all states,
military voters who are
mostly covered by federal law
are permitted to vote absentee.
The states have a range of other excuses
that justify voting absentee
like medical emergency,
confinement to jail or
confinement to medical facility,
and many states also give special help
to those who can't vote in person.
For example, in Arizona,
election officials will
deliver an absentee ballot
to voters confined due
to a medical emergency,
but that's in contrast to what's called
No-Excuse mailed ballots.
Delays in problem at polling locations
frequently cause the kind
of disturbing problems
with that we see on election day,
long lines,
broken electronic voting machines,
and people turned away
because time ran out.
state legislatures address
some of these problems
by expanding the number of
days for early in-person voting
and eliminating the
restrictions as to who can vote
absentee or by mail.
This is why 34 states in Washington DC
have what's called No-Excuse
absentee or mail-in voting.
And a quick note on terminology
since state laws are not identical,
you may see states using
different terminology
like advanced ballots,
mailed ballots,
by mail ballots,
and vote by mail ballots.
Although different terms are used
generally, they mean the same thing.
And although the word mail is
used in almost all of them,
this means that the ballots
are mailed to the voter.
Voters can send them back via the mail,
but all states also allow
the voters to drop them off
at designated secure locations.
Voters who live in these
states don't need to claim
that they will be out of the jurisdiction
or that they have any kind
of illness or emergency
that makes it impossible
for them to vote in person.
And some states like Oregon, Washington,
Hawaii and Colorado
automatically send a ballot
to every registered voter
and some people hate this.
But now is probably a good time to talk
about some of the misconceptions
about the security
or security problems of
No-Excuse mail-in ballots.
The main claim that President
Trump and various Republicans
are making is that
No-Excuse absentee ballots
are less secure than absentee ballots
that require an excuse.
President Trump says that
there are very strict protocols
for absentee ballots,
but that these strict security protocols
aren't used for mail-in ballots.
And this is strictly
speaking, not factual.
The states don't have two separate systems
for voters who will be absent
from their voting district
and those who prefer to vote by mail.
And really each state has
its own security protocols
for mailed ballots.
And here's a rundown of most
important security features.
One is that a ballot can't
be mailed to a person
unless they are an eligible
and registered voter.
This means that a person must
fill out registration forms
and have their address confirmed.
Ballots can't be forwarded
to a new address,
which means that a person must
also have a current address
to receive a ballot in the mail.
And generally ballots
arriving before election day
are stored in a secure room.
Some states use security
cameras to monitor the rooms.
Some received ballots also are
stored using special locks,
such as locks that require
bipartisan teams to open
and ballots often have a barcode,
and this means that a voter
can only be issued one ballot.
In states with barcoding,
it's incredibly difficult,
if not effectively impossible
to just simply fill out a new ballot
for someone who was
already mailed in a ballot
and had their barcode registered.
And often states that
mail every voter a ballot
use multi-layer security
envelopes in signature matching.
And since your verification
is one of the major security checks
that states use to track ballots,
every ballot is tracked in
an election management system
that tries to prevent double voting.
And often every signature that
is returned on every ballot
is then checked against
the signature on file
with the voters registration,
local officials then determine
if the ballot was returned
by an eligible voter.
Additionally, the U.S. Postal Service
recently sent a vote by mail kit
to over 11,000 local election officials.
These kits encourage them
to adopt best practices,
including the post offices
intelligent mail barcode,
which lets mailed ballots
be fully documented
as they move to and from voters
and can make it easier
to identify legal votes.
But obviously no system is perfect
and these measures haven't
stopped the President
from predicting mass voter fraud.
But let's talk about voter fraud
and how that differs
from voter suppression.
Voter fraud is the illegal
behavior of individual voters,
whether you are fraudulently
creating duplicate votes,
or you are fraudulently
voting on behalf of someone
who you're not supposed to be voting for.
Voter suppression is any
effort by the government
or other individuals to
prevent or discourage
eligible voters from registering
to vote or voting itself.
Unfortunately there's a long history
of voter suppression
tactics in this country.
They can be very simple
and violent measures
to prevent people from voting
like the murders of James
Chaney, Andrew Goodman,
and Michael Schwerner, who were killed
for registering black voters
in Mississippi in 1964.
Other suppression tactics
include requiring forms of identification
that people have difficulty obtaining
or limiting the hours for early voting
so that people have to balance
family and work obligations
with the need to show up on election day.
This is one reason why often
people argue that election day
should be a national holiday
so that more people have
the opportunity to vote
and don't need to make a choice
between going to their job and
voting in a national election
and other voter suppression tactics
can include trying to
disenfranchise people.
For example, making it
a rule that all felons
are unable to vote.
That is not a constitutional requirement.
That if you are convicted of a felony,
you automatically lose the right to vote.
Suppression tactics can
also include using software
that purges people from the
roster of eligible voters.
And sometimes all of these
tactics come together.
For example, Florida purged
thousands of alleged felons
from voter rolls in 2000.
This was before the recent
Florida constitutional amendment
that allowed felons to vote,
which is highly controversial
and is up in the courts
as we speak.
But in that particular case,
later investigators discovered
that the system purged many people
without felony convictions,
simply because they had the
same birthdate as a felon
or the first four letters of their name
seemed to match a felon's.
And in Georgia in 2018, Brian Kemp,
who was then the Georgia
secretary of state,
purged the voter rolls by
eliminating 850,000 voters
who hadn't voted in a while.
This was called the use
it or lose it approach.
And Kemp was then elected
governor that year.
- I'm Brian Kemp, this is Jake.
Young man interested
in one of my daughters.
- Yes sir.
- But apart from voter suppression,
which is its own thing and
deserves its own video,
there is voter fraud, which is ostensibly
what a lot of people in
the Trump administration
are worried about.
So what is voter fraud
and how common is it?
Well, there's several different categories
of potential voter fraud.
And let's start with something
called double voting.
Double voting is when
a person votes twice.
Obviously one person can only vote once
in any particular election.
Now to prove double voting,
you just need proof that
someone voted more than once.
And most states require voting
documentation to be saved
such as signed poll books.
Double voting is actually extremely rare.
The reason for this,
it was just that it isn't worth
it for a criminal conviction
to add one incremental
vote to a candidate's total
when any particular candidate
is going to have thousands
and thousands of votes.
Each act of voter fraud
in connection with a federal election,
risks five years in
prison and a $10,000 fine,
in addition to any state penalties.
For double voting to throw an election,
you would need thousands
of people in a jurisdiction
willing to take that risk
or you'd need one person
to vote many, many times,
which increases the
chance of getting caught.
Often what appears to be a double vote
is actually just confusion
about the person's identity.
In 2004, for example,
two Kathleen Sullivans
living in New Jersey were
confused for each other,
that's mistake, but not voter fraud.
Then you have the classic
kind of voter fraud
involving dead voters.
The media frequently run
stories about dead people voting
only to find out after
further investigation
that this is based on clerical errors.
More often than the
clerical errors though,
is that people will simply
cast an absentee ballot.
And then in the interim
before the election is over,
they pass away.
And while there are certainly stories
of people filling the ballot boxes
with the names of the deceased
at the turn of the 20th century
and things like the
Chicago Political Machine
of 100 years ago,
in the modern era, this
kind of voter fraud
is extraordinarily rare.
Another common claim is
that people will register
with fraudulent addresses like
vacant lots of storage units
in order to get more votes.
This obviously runs into the same problems
with trying to use the same name,
to be able to vote more than once,
but not many fake address claims
have been substantiated over the years.
And some states maintain a
list of properties and lots
that are allegedly vacant
only to find out later
that they actually now hold houses.
This actually happened in
Missouri in the year 2000,
officials also mistakenly
challenged people
like Barbara Taylor, a Washington voter,
who listed her address
as a storage facility.
It turns out that Taylor
managed the storage company
and lived in an apartment on site
and had lived there for 12 years.
And her address was in fact legitimate.
And then there's the possibility
of felony-barred voters.
And this one's controversial
because in many states,
people who are convicted of
felonies are allowed to vote.
Ironically, it's actually far more likely
that a state will purge eligible voters
from the voting rolls when
they're trying to purge felons
than it is for people who
are convicted of felonies
from accidentally voting or
even intentionally voting
despite felony conviction.
And then finally there is
the possibility of voting
by non-citizens.
President Trump and his advisors claim,
that non-citizen immigrants voted on mass,
but there's been no evidence
of illegal immigrants,
really voting at all, let
alone in large numbers.
This could be because the
penalty for illegally voting
is deportation while
the payoff is minuscule.
Again, one marginal vote
in a general election
and of the few documented cases
where an ineligible immigrant voted
most involve innocent mistakes.
Sometimes people who are going through
the naturalization process
are given voter registration forms,
which they turn in
before they have actually
become naturalized citizens.
As worth considering how difficult
this kind of fraud would
be to pull off at scale,
in Hawaii, in 2000, there were allegations
that 533 non-citizens registered to vote,
but an investigation revealed
that 144 of those registered voters
actually became citizens and
then were eligible to vote.
At least 61 asked the state
to cancel their registrations
when they realized that
they were ineligible,
two others were stopped at
the polls by poll workers
and no, never voted
and there were no reports substantiating
that any ineligible immigrant
actually voted in that election.
So it's worth asking, how
widespread is election fraud?
Well, the Heritage Foundation
and which is known as a
fairly conservative think tank
maintains a database of documented
instances of voter fraud.
They found that over the past 20 years,
about 250 million votes
have been cast by mail-in
ballot nationally.
And during that time,
there have been just over 1200
cases of fraud of all forms
resulting in 1100 criminal convictions.
Of these cases,
204 involve the fraudulent
use of absentee ballots,
143 resulted in criminal convictions,
that amounts to about
0.0006% of all votes casts.
So when you break that down,
that works out to an average
of maybe seven or eight cases of fraud
involving mailed or absentee
ballots per year nationally.
And remember, Oregon
has been mailing ballots
to all registered voters for 20 years.
So far 50 million ballots
have been cast in Oregon alone
with just two verified fraud cases
resulting in conviction.
That's 0.00004%.
But that's not to say that
we shouldn't be concerned
about the security of our vote.
Obviously the strength of our democracy
relies on our votes being
authentic and secure,
but we should also probably consider
what kinds of fraud cases
have been discovered recently,
as it regards is mail-in ballots.
The answer is that there's
been almost no fraud
considering the millions of
ballots that have been cast.
Of course you don't have
to take my word for it.
You can actually take the word
of the Trump Campaign itself
because the Trump Campaign
is actually filing suit
in a number of different states
to try and prevent changes
to the way that elections are run,
to make it easier for people to vote.
And in particular, the Trump Campaign
is actually suing in Pennsylvania
to stop the legislature
from allowing people to
vote via drop-off mailboxes
in places other than
designated voting stations.
The Trump Campaign alleged
that there was widespread
voter fraud in Pennsylvania,
and therefore the changes
could not take place.
After a lengthy discovery battle
where the defendants demanded
that the Trump Campaign
actually provided evidence of the fraud
that they claim was taking place,
the judge ordered the Trump
Campaign to provide the evidence
of widespread voter fraud
that the Trump Campaign claimed existed.
And when push came to shove,
the Trump Campaign provided basically
a half dozen news articles
that sort of hinted at things going on,
which did not actually talk
about widespread mail-in voter fraud.
So the Trump Campaign's best evidence
basically showed nothing of the kind.
And notice I said the Trump Campaign
rather than the President himself,
because it's the company that runs
the president's reelection campaign
that is responsible for these lawsuits,
which is incredibly problematic
because the campaign
can use all of the funds at its disposal,
which includes the funds
that people have donated
for the President's reelection.
Those kinds of campaign contributions
are being used to further
what a lot of people are calling
voter suppression tactics
to roll back amendments to voting laws,
which would allow for increased
franchisement of people
in states like Pennsylvania and Nevada,
and believe it or not,
the biggest verified
election fraud scandal
in recent history was actually
committed in North Carolina
by Republican operative,
Leslie McCrae Dowless,
who in 2019 was charged
with three felony counts
of about destruction of justice,
two counts of conspiring to
commit obstruction of justice,
two counts of possession
of absentee ballots,
perjury and solicitation
to commit perjury.
Operatives working for
Dowless illegally collected
and sometimes filled in absentee ballots
on behalf of Republican
Mark Harris's campaign.
Harris won by less than a 1000 votes.
And as a result of the fraud,
the state ordered a new election.
Now, regardless of whether
there is extensive documentation
of actual voter fraud or not,
that hasn't stopped the President
from saying that he wants to do something
to change the election.
So the question is,
can the president change
the entire elective system
through executive order?
And the answer is that the President
does not have the constitutional authority
to make unilateral changes
to the election system.
These issues are largely
enshrined in federal statutes
and state law, which an executive
order can't really touch,
but the President can
undermine voting and confidence
in the outcome of the election.
And that may be what
the President is doing.
Recently, new Postmaster
General Louis DeJoy,
a Trump donor, just instituted changes
in the way that the U.S.
Postal Service works.
Reducing overtime for postal workers,
even if that means that mail
that's ready to be delivered,
sits at the local post
office for additional days.
President Trump argues that
this is all about building
more efficient postal service,
but the timing of these changes coincides
with the president's outbursts and tirades
against mail-in voting.
House Representative, Carolyn Maloney,
recently sent a letter about
the reported operating changes
to DeJoy complaining that, the quote,
"Increases in mail delivery timing
would impair the ability
of ballots to be received
and counted in a timely manner."
To many people,
the sudden changes to
the U.S. Postal Service
look like a voter suppression tactic.
A majority of states reject ballots
if they aren't delivered by election day,
even if they are postmarked in advance.
So a slowdown in the
mail could be disastrous
for mail-in ballots that
are sent far ahead of time.
That just simply don't
arrive by election day.
And the president has repeatedly stated,
that the election must be
decided on the same day
that voting takes place,
even though there is
no federal or state law
that requires the actual outcome
to be decided on the same day.
In reality, the outcome of
the presidential election
is not official until the completion
of the canvass of votes and
certification of the results.
The canvass means
aggregating and confirming
every valid ballot cast and counted,
which includes absentee,
early voting, Election Day,
provisional, challenged,
uniformed and overseas citizens.
This doesn't happen in one night.
Election Day is November 2nd,
states have until December 8th, 2020
to resolve election disputes.
And this means recounts and lawsuits
must be completed by then.
And states have a minimum of 35 days
to certify who won the
most votes in that state.
The person with the most votes
wins each state's electors
with a few exceptions,
and the electoral college
meets on December 14th, 2020
and cast their ballots.
The ballots are of course
immediately transmitted
to various people.
And December 23rd is the deadline
for receipt of all electors
ballots from all of the states.
However, there's no penalty
for missing that particular deadline.
On January 6, 2021,
Congress is going to
meet to count the votes
and Inauguration Day is going
to be January 20th, 2021,
but as promised the Trump
Campaign is actually making good
on the president's threats to
try and stop mail-in voting.
And the Trump Campaign has
actually sued the state of Nevada
over the state's new law,
expanding mail-in voting for
the 2020 general election.
According to the lawsuit,
making all voters a
ballot makes voter fraud,
quote, "Inevitable".
The lawsuit also claims that
nailing all voters ballots
disenfranchises rural voters
violating the Equal Protection Clause.
The lawsuit takes issue
with a section of the law
requiring County clerks to quote,
"Establish procedures for the processing
and counting of ballots."
The Trump Campaign's
problem with this is that,
it's up to each County clerk
to establish the best
procedures for counting
rather than a uniform system statewide.
And you may agree or disagree
with the various
different counties systems
that they put in place in which
there was a standardized
system throughout the state,
but the President's
Campaign doesn't have a role
in making Nevada law.
And remember the
constitution gives the states
the right to administer
their own elections.
And it probably shouldn't surprise you
that making an Equal Protection claim
on behalf of rural voters
doesn't make any sense at all.
They're not a protected class
and I don't see how an
Equal Protection claim
works in this particular context.
No, personally, I think as
many people of all stripes,
whether Democrat or
Republican should vote.
Voting is a public good,
and both federal and state governments
should take more steps
to facilitate voting,
especially in these COVID times.
And mail-in voting seems
like a pretty easy step
to make that happen
because we're all staying home more often,
not just cause of COVID,
but because it's so ridiculously hot out
and I've heard stories of
people attending zoom calls
with formal business attire on top
and swimming trunks on the bottom.
I of course would never do that.
But if I did do that,
I'd wear a Mack Weldon's
awesome swimming trunks.
I'm also not going to rip the suit off
when I finished this video
and jump in the pool,
wearing Mack Weldon's
designer swim trunks,
look great in and out of the water,
but here's a picture of the
last time I wore those trunks.
That's definitely me and not
a stock photo of a model.
I really needed a tan there.
Mack Weldon is a men's
essential clothing company
that focuses on smart
design and premium fabrics.
If I'm not in court or on
a zoom call with the judge,
I'm often wearing Mack Weldon,
and I've tried their polos,
their t-shirts and their shorts.
And of course they're
world famous boxer briefs.
And if you're watching this channel,
you're an adult and you probably deserve
to have really nice boxer briefs.
And I can tell you, they
make a world of difference.
I've ordered Mack Weldon with
my own money multiple times
and it's really easy because
I've had multiple sizes shipped
to try on,
and then I just returned
the ones that didn't fit
and kept the ones that fit perfectly.
And if you would like to try Mack Weldon
and you'd like 20% off your first order,
just go to mackweldon.com/legaleagle,
or use the Promo Code
legaleagle at checkout.
Or you can click on the
link in the description
and with Mack Weldon's loyalty program,
you can get 20% off, free shipping
and access to new products first.
It's automatic when you sign up and order
at mackweldon.com/legaleagle,
or you can click on the
link in the description
and with Mack Weldon's loyalty program,
you can get 20% off with
free strip free stripping.
No, there will not be any free stripping.
With Mack Weldon's
loyalty program, though,
you can get 20% off with free shipping
and access to new products.
It's automatic when you sign up and order
at mackweldon.com/legaleagle,
or use the Promo Code
legaleagle at checkout
for 20% off your first order.
And of course, clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And if you wanna try out
their famous boxer briefs,
you can decide for any reason
that you're not satisfied
and you can just keep them
and still get a free refund
because who wants to
return used underwear.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Do you think that voter
fraud is a real issue
or is it really just the
tail wagging the dog?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out my other
real law reviews over here,
where I talk about all of the crazy things
coming out of the Trump administration
and all the legal issues that
we've never had to deal with.
So just click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.